unity bright on 8 news now is sponsored
by our community pride partners finley
automotive group southwest medical part
of optum care and silver state schools
credit union
southwest medical hospice care the
sponsors of this segment provide the
right care at the right time and with
the right companion
my name is billy rayford and i am
a native texan
who moved here to las vegas in 1979.
i had a wonderful career in the clark
county school district and i'm a retired
educator i am widowed
and
that's what brought me to
this volunteer role at southwest medical
hospice my
husband
was
a
hospice patient
his condition was
he never wanted to go to a facility he
wanted to stay home
and so
i could do that i said if you want to
put up with me we can do that
so
we were able to
um
carry out his wishes
and with the support of the team
there wasn't a thing that i can remember
that we needed that wasn't provided
and so we were able to get through some
very difficult times
with their support
and all we had to do was call if i had a
question someone was always available to
answer the questions and if we needed
something more urgent
there was a response so often we think
of hospice volunteers is being
face to face with patients that has not
been my experience
my experience has been more support
preparing
for the caregivers and the professionals
to be in the homes
and
having everything they need to for
smooth operation
the first thing i got involved in was
the greeting card program
where
southwest medical hospice
sends greeting cards to patients and
their families they try to do that once
a month just a note of encouragement
the second part of the program is i
volunteer in the southwest medical
offices
to provide the support to the care team
and the last thing that i've been
involved in is
what is called the southwest medical
tuck in program
and each week volunteers call patients
and their families to make sure
that they have the medications supplies
and equipment and whatever other support
they may need over the weekend
so that there's no gap in service what i
appreciated most about
the way southwest medical runs their
volunteer program is
first of all
patients are a priority
number two
i need the tools or volunteer needs the
tools
to
put the patient's priorities first and
that came with training i absolutely
would encourage others to be involved in
hospice care if they want to chop
vegetables for
a nutrition session they might want to
do that or if they want to volunteer and
sit with the patient to give a family
member an opportunity to go grocery
shopping
or to go to an appointment or just a
respite two-hour session it's so
appreciated by the families by the
patients and it's so rewarding as a
volunteer
we want to say thank you again to
southwest medical for sponsoring this
segment and for being one of our
community pride partners
now let's